when you look back at all this imagery
from the White House even though it
doesn't look stiff and staged like
previous administrations you're going to
see that there's like a heavy hand just
in terms of the way that this
administration created an inside view as
if it was an administration that was a
version of reality television
[Music]
thank you thank you
[Applause]
minutes before being sworn into office
for his first term as nearly two million
people waited for him outside of the US
Capitol building president-elect Barack
Obama stepped in front of the mirror
he face rumors questioning the origin of
his birth his political opponents had
cast his religious beliefs into doubt
the Obama administration would address
this crisis of perception through the
skillful use of photography and a venn
new technology of social media
Michael Shaw's the publisher of bag news
notes a site dedicated to the analysis
of news images Shaw has been keeping a
close eye on how President Obama's image
is crafted for public consumption when
the White House chooses what image it
wants to present to the world they'll
put it on their White House website or
they'll put it on Flickr and that will
be a picture that will be if it's a
beautiful picture and composed in a
particular way and have a lot of drama
and exploit a lot of trappings of
patriotism that's a picture that a lot
of media is going to publish along with
their news account the White House's
social media strategy began as a
coordinated response to the swarm of
rumors about the president's religious
beliefs and the origin of his birth over
time it proved to be so effective at
shaping the president's identity that
the White House photography office would
soon threaten to make independent
coverage of the president obsolete you
had a new president virtually unknown
African American had a Muslim that had a
middle name that a lot of people
associated with is Islam when we've got
all this terror and anxiety we now turn
to admitted and unrepentant terrorists
William Ayers and the relationship with
him that Obama continues to try and
downplay eighteen percent of Americans
think Obama is Muslim up from 11 percent
more than a year ago I can't trust Obama
I have read about him and he's not he's
not he's a he's an Arab and so the White
House they went to create an identity
for the president and they did that in
very interesting ways one would be to
associate in much more popular culture
so you'd see an amazing number of photos
of himmat with celebrities for example I
can't tell you how many pictures that
are with of George Clooney on the White
House Flickr site this I'm sure it's in
like the double digits for sure it was
clear that these guys were creating
their own imagery and they're
distributing it to the press and the
press was eating it up Pete Souza took a
picture that was so powerful in terms of
playing off a pop off of popular culture
it's Obama indoors I think he was
underground at one of the pyramids and
he's wearing a hat and that makes him
look exactly like your Harrison Ford
character and Indiana Jones and it's
that kind of image when your counter
when you're trying to create a
counterpoint to this narrative that's in
the culture that can be extraordinarily
powerful and neutralizing before taking
office Abraham Lincoln was seen as an
unsophisticated country lawyer from the
backwoods of a remote western state his
opponents called him a baboon but
through the eyes of photographer Matthew
Brady Lincoln was posed lit and
retouched into a refined statesman Brady
he once said made him president only
three photographs exist of Franklin
Roosevelt in a wheelchair the Secret
Service would seize the camera and
destroy the film of anyone who recorded
instances of his disability decades
after his death millions of Americans
were convinced their president was able
bodied the first photographer on the
presidential payroll
yo'ii she Okamoto had unprecedented
access to the president he even captured
President Johnson in moments that were
less than flattering Pete Souza is the
first White House photographer to
distribute his images using social media
more than any Administration in modern
history press photographers have been
barred from covering White House events
while Sousa and his staff enjoy nearly
unrestricted access to the president
with an abundance of popular image
sharing sites the white house no longer
needs the independent media to present
its point of view to the public the
president interrupted a fundraising
event all the guests basically stood and
waited and the and the media by the way
the press photographers were all kept
behind a rope line while the president
and his photographer Pete Souza were on
this bus and then the president chose us
place to sit and they had special
lighting from the outside and then the
way he posed himself looking out the
window was almost directly patterned
after the famous picture of Rosa Parks
looking out the window so if we think
about the difference between having the
press on that bus you wouldn't have this
incredibly iconic image of the president
I visualized himself with this
historical civil rights figure in the
middle of a campaign you would have had
something where they had to negotiate
the scene and probably create something
that perhaps was a lot more mundane
probably something much more human and
real and variable than this incredibly
staged picture that the press was
excluded from president obama took a
moment to sit on a bus where Rosa Parks
changed the course of the civil rights
movement forever
once again the media took the bait
reporting on white house photos without
question
ABC News called it a personal moment for
Obama while NPR said that the picture
speaks for itself
while republishing the president's
prepared statement to the media pretty
amazing I think he's pretty well
connected to folks in this country after
six years of gradually losing access to
the president it took an Air Force one
flight to South Africa for journalists
to lose their patience independent
photographers were barred from shooting
the Obama and Bush families aboard the
flight while Pete Souza's photos went
straight from the White House Flickr
page to television and web publications
around the
and they were never asked to come in and
take and to shoot a picture of what was
very much a social setting a situation
that time to kill it was really a
blatant decision on the part of the
administration to exclude the press and
the press confronted White House
spokesman Jay Carney while the cameras
were rolling anyone here can tell you
that there's less access than under the
Bush administration and it was President
Obama who talked about transparency but
in a hallmark of his administration so
isn't it sort of the problem is that he
has set up a standard himself that he's
not every president has had meetings
that the press didn't cover every pret
every White House has released
photographs but Carney refused to accept
that the administration was anything
less than fully open to the press in
response thirty eight news organizations
signed a letter of protest to the White
House stating as surely as if they were
placing a hand over journalists camera
lens officials in this administration
are blocking the public from having an
independent view of important functions
of the executive branch of government in
a rare reversal White House
photographers got in front of the lens
and took their case directly to the
public if there are situations where the
president is performing his official
duties and they choose to not let the
press cover it but then they release
their own photograph our complaint is
why aren't you bringing in the
independent news photographers to cover
this that we have significantly less
access to the print to this president
than previous presidents the White House
response to the criticism was mocked by
the press corps some of this anyway has
to do with you know fundamental
transformations in the media that of
which we and other institutions are
simply participants and but not we did
not create the Internet this
administration and
it was told on don't go ahead access you
can put out a million pictures a day
from the White House photographer you
bar and what I'm saying that it is and
what I'm saying in is that we've the
response in the part of the White House
I think has ranged from vindictive to
patronizing the White House shot back by
taking photos of the press corps and
posting them on the White House
Instagram page the press did not seem
amused and the White House released an
image of photographers being herded into
the Oval Office that was at the very
least unflattering the whole thing read
is punitive it's like here's your
picture you know hear it you know get in
go and and look you know you have access
what's the problem in a tacit admission
that he had treated the press unfairly
President Obama sought to smooth things
over what is your new year's resolution
my new year's resolution is to be nicer
to the White House press corps despite
the president's call for day taunt the
White House continues to block the press
from photographing subjects they
consider sensitive like this meeting
with the Dalai Lama even selfies were
threatened with a ban after this
seemingly impromptu shot by Red Sox
slugger David Ortiz was retweeted by
Samsung to promote their smartphones
maybe the fact that they had to go back
and redo the swearing end with John
Roberts the first time turned out to be
a harbinger on this issue then I will
execute
the off faithfully the president office
of President of the United States
paperwork because they're creating layer
upon layer upon layer of storylines and
and scenes and because they can
distribute directly through all these
different channels they there's really
not much downside to it there's not much
accountability all over the world
governments are producing idealized
versions of their own identities on
social media from 10 Downing Street on
Flickr to Bashar al-assad's Instagram
page we may never see our politicians in
quite the same way ever again
[Music]